[Musique]
tout simplement Paul niveau de
transparence et d'urgence attendues pour
les Canadiens et les Canadiens
les renseignements que j'ai examiné sont
et doivent rester sec
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que devait Johnson a surpris
bien du monde la semaine dernière en
écartant l'idée d'une enquête publique
qui selon lui aurait été bien peu public
à cause des renseignements secrets une
réflexion qui n'a pas calmé les parties
d'opposition qui maintiennent qu'il
s'agit de la seule option viable pour
faire la lumière dans le dossier de
l'ingérence étrangère dans ce contexte
juste un Trudeau pourra-t-il un jour
tourner la page sur toute cette histoire
voyons voir ce qu'on pense mes
collaborateurs à les castorgettes
animateurs de midi info et il s'y
première et chroniqueurs au Toronto Star
le magazine d'actualité et Michel serget
et chroniqueur à La Presse et à
Radio-Canada bonjour à vous trois
bonjour Alex surpris de la
recommandation monsieur de la conclusion
monsieur Johnson la semaine dernière
oui surpris quand même parce que il y
avait une manière de faire diminuer la
tension politique autour de ce sujet là
et c'était de déclencher une enquête
publique évidemment que allait être
différente des autres en cas publique
qu'on a vu le monsieur Johnston on vient
de l'entendre dans l'extrait en raison
de dire que beaucoup de documents
d'informations qui devraient rester
confidentiel s'il y avait une enquête
publique donc des éléments qui restent à
huit clos des documents caviés sauf pour
évidemment ceux qui travaillent pour la
commission d'enquête tout ça est vrai je
pense pas que personne s'attendait
vraiment ce qu'il y a une enquête
publique 100% public sur un sujet aussi
délicat que l'interférence étrangère
dans la démocratie canadienne là où je
suis moins certain c'est quand il dit
grosso modo que quiconque aurait accès
au même document au même entrevues que
lui a mené avec des hauts responsables
politiques et du SCRS ça arriverait à la
même conclusion avec lui ça je suis
moins certain parce que d'abord il y a
un processus autour d'une enquête
publique avec la possibilité de
contraintes des témoins à se présenter
contre une contrainte aussi la pour la
présentation de documents la production
de documents mais il y a aussi une
question de et j'en avais rien monsieur
Johnston mais de formation il est avocat
oui mais il est surtout en universitaire
ancien recteur en 5 gouverneur général
est-ce que un jeu formé pour ce type
d'enquête là ou du moins qu'il y a
l'habitude d'analyser des preuves
d'analyser des témoignages en arrivera à
la même conclusion est-ce que des
procureurs chevronnés qui dans la vie
posent des questions retourne des
pierres en arrivera la même conclusion
on ne sait pas quel type d'entrevue
monsieur Johnston a mené derrière des
porte-clés avec des hauts responsables
avec du SARL les questions étaient
bonnes explique les réponses étaient
évasives est-ce qu'il les a cru sur
parole est-ce qu'on pourrait
contre-interroger ces personnes là pour
avoir un petit peu plus d'informations
moi je pense que dans un processus
balisé d'enquête public en partie et à
huis clos en partie on aurait pu aller
au fond d'une histoire plutôt que de se
contenter de ce que le rapporteur
spécial a eu comme conclusion
j'entends dans cette Michel Chantal
là-dessus
sur le fond on peut ou pas être d'accord
avec des voix de Johnson et se dire lui
il le veut tout ce que nous on n'a pas
vu et tout ce que l'opposition a pas vu
non plus c'est à dire le portrait
complet et selon lui ça ressemble pas à
l'impression qu'on a en lisant les
reportages qui découlent des fuites
c'est possible mais sur la forme il y a
un vice de forme dans la mesure où le
rituel ça compte c'est comme de dire et
là oui ma comparaison est voiture mais
quand même c'est comme de dire on sait
où on est pas mal sûr que Madame machin
ou monsieur machin a tué X mais c'est
important pour la justice et la
crédibilité de l'institution qu'on en
fasse la preuve en public
compense à travers le rituel de
d'éplucher tout ça d'autre part monsieur
Johnston se défend son intégrité c'est
possible totalement de le croire et de
dire oui c'est un homme intègre et de
savoir qu'il n'a pas la crédibilité
malgré tout dans l'état actuel du débat
d'être la personne qui dit à la fin moi
je suis l'arbitre et je sais que j'ai
raison et vous pouvez aller voir vous
allez me donner raison c'est inévitable
ça tient pas la route d'autres parts
monsieur Johnston dit faut arrêter de
faire de la politique autour de ça de la
reine partizane il vient de le remettre
là faute d'autres de forums pour avoir
ce débat alors pour toutes ces raisons
là
on en arrive à la conclusion que David
Johnson était probablement pas la bonne
personne pour l'exercice pas parce qu'il
connaît juste un Trudeau qui ont ce qui
est ensemble ou bien qui a été à la
Fondation tous les deux mais parce qu'il
est
dur d'oreille sur les notes politiques
et l'ambiance politique Michel c'est ça
parce que c'est le frère légale versus
le flair politique puis monsieur Johnson
qui vendredi
vous savez quoi je suis toujours l'homme
la situation puis je vais continuer à
faire le travail
il arrive dans des procès que on demande
à régulation d'un juge et très souvent
le juge dit je ne crois pas que je ne
suis pas impartial mais pour des
apparences de la justice je vais me
recruter et c'est ça que je devrais
faire aujourd'hui il y a quelque chose
dans salle logique qui ne marche pas
easy si on fait une enquête publique il
va falloir que tellement de choses
soient cachées qu'on donnera pas de la
vraie transparence alors à cause de ça
on fera pas de transparence du tout
il est possible de faire une commission
d'enquête il s'en est fait la commission
McDonald's sur la police au Québec
toutes ces choses là avaient des
documents secrets qui pouvaient pas
donner au public qui pouvaient pas
montrer qui était fortement qu'à
regarder toutes ces choses là se font le
public les compréhens on s'attend pas ce
que c'est enquête là soit complètement
public avec l'ambassadeur de Chine dans
le box puis des choses comme ça
mais on peut faire une enquête faire de
la pédagogie et c'est peut-être ça la
chose la plus importante
c'est quelque chose de très sérieux les
gens étrangères démocratie si on peut la
commission d'enquête serait probablement
été le meilleur moyen de faire cette
pédagogie là
du public surprend l'analogie du Chantal
tantôt on fait un procès parce qu'on
veut s'assurer que le public a confiance
en l'intégrité du système Chantal où
est-ce que ça nous amène là Monsieur
Trudeau cette semaine a dit bah écoutez
moi j'accepte les recommandations de
Monsieur Johnston est parti de position
disent moi n'est pas d'accord puis on
réclame encore une enquête publique
alors est-ce qu'on réussit à tourner la
page à un moment ou un autre là-dessus
ou pas
bon il y a un seul chef de position qui
a accepté de voir le portrait selon moi
il devrait tous accepter pourquoi il
devrait tous accepter parce qu'on peut
pas dire je veux pas savoir et continuer
à poser des questions en supposant
je suis convaincu que Monsieur signe
après avoir vu tout ça va avoir encore
plein de questions qui va pouvoir poser
au gouvernement et dans les fêtes il va
avoir un petit peu plus de crédibilité
surtout s'il sort en disant j'ai vu tout
ça mais je pense encore qu'il devrait y
avoir une enquête publique parce qu'on
va savoir qu'il le dit en connaissance
de cause quand même ça vaut un peu plus
cher que dire cacher c'est fait que je
ne veux pas voir parce que ça me dérange
de pas pouvoir les interpréter à ma
façon souvent ou parfois fantaisiste
je pense pas que le NPD d'après tout ce
que j'ai vu est en train de dire et à
terme on va faire une mention de censure
qui va dire si le gouvernement que c'est
pas une enquête publique dans ce cas-là
on retire notre confiance au
gouvernement et je ne crois pas qu'il y
ait au sein de l'électorat une volonté
de voir une campagne électorale si le
premier juillet
sur ce genre d'Anjou là mais je prévois
une fin de session plutôt houleuse je
crois aussi que les libéraux se disent
quelque part et je dis pas qu'ils ont
raison que des élections complémentaires
qui s'en viennent le 19 juin que s'ils
gardent leur mise et même améliore leur
score dans certains cas ça va être la
preuve que c'est eux qui ont raison je
pense que ça va être une mauvaise
lecture mais je sens qu'ils sont tentés
d'aller dans cette voie là qui est
Michel ensuite Alex où est-ce que ça
nous amène
[Musique]
de nouvelles révélations sur ce qui se
passe ça va je pense pour l'instant est
un espèce de statu quo les parties
d'opposition vont ensuite réclamer
l'enquête publique ce côté du
gouvernement va dire on a maintenant la
caution de quelqu'un qui dit c'est pas
la meilleure manière de fonctionner
s'il y a des nouvelles révélations
importantes dans les prochaines semaines
la pression va donc continuer à
augmenter sur le gouvernement puis on va
être un peu de retour à la case départ
c'est un peu seul la difficulté pour
juste intrudo c'est que l'arme du
rapporteur spécial va nous faire qu'un
temps s'il y a un moment donné ça
continue à déraper il y a de limite à
brandir cette cette ce rapport-là
surtout qu'on regarde nouveau sondage
lingostway on voit que la population est
assez sceptique à l'impression que le
gouvernement libéral gère mal ce dossier
là le rapporteur spécial n'a pas la
confiance de la majorité des Canadiens
et bien les Canadiens qui se demandent
si tu as la bonne personne pour ça donc
les les messages des parties
d'opposition particulièrement du Parti
conservateur du Bloc québécois sur la
crédibilité
il est dans les situations de voir ces
appuis
de façon ponctuelle et continuer à
s'éroder un peu à cause de ça ça ne lève
pas c'est sûr que ça donne l'aidement
puis être le seul à avoir raison dans
tous les parties d'opposition sont
synonyme c'est toujours délicats pour un
premier ministre alors ça c'est la
première des choses la deuxième c'est
que faut pas oublier que qu'est-ce qui a
été le départ de ça ça a été des fuites
dans les médias monsieur Johnson a beau
dire c'était frayant qu'on a fait ça et
que les friteurs sont à blâmés pour la
situation pourrait en avoir d'autres et
là la chambre si je recule le
gouvernement va avoir de la vitesse à
répondre peut-être qu'on va se retrouver
au mois de septembre dans une situation
plus délicate pour le gouvernement que
s'il y avait une enquête publique mais
bon ils vont vivre leur décision entre
temps il y aura encore du travail
suis-je en train de rapport final d'ici
la fin du mois d'octobre là cette
semaine autre sujet qui a retenu
l'attention à Québec petit changement de
cap du gouvernement logo encore une fois
disons certains sur l'immigration cette
fois ce fameux seuil de 50 000 monsieur
Legault disait à Léo delà de ça ce
serait suicidaire durant la campagne
électorale on lui reposer la question
cette semaine quand il a ouvert la porte
à l'eau et là dessus il a répondu ceci
à partir du moment où on est capable
puis une réelle ouverture de la part du
gouvernement fédéral de dire
l'augmentation c'est seulement les
francophones ou des gens qui maîtrisent
le français ça vient complètement
changer la situation
[Musique]
Michel il y a eu le troisième lien il y
a quelques semaines puis là on a
l'impression que c'est un autre qui
volte-face en tout cas c'est une grosse
promesse de campagne de Monsieur le
groupe et là on marche un peu sur la
peinture qu'est-ce qu'on comprend
je ne me plaiderai pas de voir le
gouvernement
électorales en faisant la bonne chose et
pour le troisième bien et pour ça mais
ce qu'on vient d'entendre de monsieur
Legault ont changé parce que j'ai parlé
à tawa finalement on peut avoir juste
des francophones il pouvait le faire
envers moi de l'Entente Canada Québec
sur l'immigration depuis le début de son
premier mandat alors ça ne tient pas
mais encore une fois voici une politique
et qui attendait électoral a été
démontré de façon assez fermée de façon
à ce qui manquait l'ouverture envers les
migration qui a présenté l'immigration
comme un danger plutôt que comme une
possibilité
d'aider le Québec là donc c'est qu'on
dit non non c'est la solution c'est plus
le problème c'est la solution
d'abord il faudra qu'il fasse la
pédagogie de ça même si beaucoup de gens
y croient et d'autre part
le gouvernement doit maintenant dire bon
ben on est sérieux on veut faire ça et
une fois qu'elle prenait aussi disent
ben moi j'ai changé d'idées j'ai évolué
j'ai changé
ma façon de penser parce que le problème
de ce monsieur disait monsieur Lego
c'était le soutexte le sous-texte du
danger des migration puisqu'il y a pas
une très bonne chose à faire ressortir
dans une société Alec monsieur Lego en
début de dans le premier mandat avait
dit quand on fait des erreurs je suis
prête à les reconnaître est-ce que c'est
un peu chaud qu'on vient de voir cette
semaine est-ce que c'est un réajustement
en fonction d'une politique qui était
probablement peut-être mal réfléchi
François Legault l'immigration a jamais
été sa force a toujours été un dossier
avec lequel il n'est pas très à l'aise
avec lequel il le louvoyé puis on a
l'impression que parfois il y avait un
peu plus de méconnaissance et plus de
politique dans ces déclarations que de
faire réels
moins quand j'ai regardé la conférence
de presse je lui dis
j'avais eu l'impression que c'était la
première fois qu'on avait une ou un
véritable ministre de l'immigration qui
comprend de quoi il parle que Simon
Genin barrette était un homme
intelligent mais qui faisait beaucoup de
politiques avec l'immigration et que
Jean Boulet était là un peu en attendant
que les élections arrivent puis on
allait le remplacer éventuellement et là
Christine Frechette est arrivé comprend
les dossiers s'y intéresse depuis
longtemps et invisiblement changé le ton
sur lequel on parle de l'immigration à
l'intérieur du gouvernement et là
probablement convaincu d'une certaine
manière François Legault d'aller dans
une direction qui aurait pu prendre il y
a longtemps je suis d'accord avec Michel
tous les leviers qu'on veut activer
actuellement existe depuis maintenant
plusieurs années on aurait pu le faire
mais donc on a décidé peut-être parce
que madame trraichette est plus
convaincante d'aller dans cette
direction là
c'est la première fois depuis quatre
cinq ans que j'entends le gouvernement
est particulièrement François Legault
parlait de l'immigration comme étant une
solution soit au déclin français soit la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre et non pas
comme une menace à nos valeurs faire des
liens avec la violence dire qu'ils
travaillent pas passé ils sont pas assez
payés il y avait toujours quelque chose
qui fonctionnait pas avec l'immigration
qui est à aller brosser Ottawa pour
récupérer des pouvoirs même si on savait
pas trop qu'est-ce qu'on voulait faire
avec ses pouvoirs là c'est la première
fois qu'on a une stratégie cohérente qui
peut fonctionner qui sera pas facile à
appliquer mais qui peut fonctionner pour
lequel on a un discours nuancé la seule
chose que changer assis à cette table là
c'est Christine Frechette doit bien
avoir une raison qu'on avait un peu plus
en entrevue qui effectivement connaît
très très bien le dossier Chantal
là-dessus
de cette politique là c'est qu'on peut
comprendre à quoi elle sert et quelles
sont ses objectifs c'est peut-être
ambitieux peut-être l'exécution va
laisser à désirer mais au moins ça
s'inscrit dans une démarche qu'on peut
comprendre en termes de politique
publique ce qui était pas le cas de
déclarations précédentes ce qui est un
petit peu ironique Michel a parlé de
François Legault qui va devoir faire de
la pédagogie parce qu'il y a un certain
groupe d'électeurs qui peuvent être
réfractaires à l'idée d'augmenter les
seuils d'immigration c'est qu'il va
trouver il va se trouver senti
détricoter ce qui lui a aidé à tripoter
avec ces déclarations jusqu'à présent et
c'est rare qu'on voit le même politicien
qui dit des choses pas en campagne une
fois deux fois et qui arrive avec une
politique qui va dans un sens selon moi
nettement plus constructif d'autres
parts à chaque fois et sur deux
campagnes je l'ai couvert à moins de
dossier de l'immigration et de cette
entente quand elle a été conclue et à
chaque fois que Monsieur le logo en
parlait c'est un peu mystérieux
qu'est-ce qu'il pensait qu'il avait
besoin de plus considérant toutes les
leviers dont il se servaient pas donc il
s'en allait comme dans le cas du
troisième lien dans un cul-de-sac
c'est effectivement constat intéressant
j'aurais voulu qu'on parle de l'alberto
malheureusement c'est tout le temps
qu'il nous reste alors on va attendre de
voir le résultat demain puis on en
parlera la semaine prochaine Alex
Chantal Michel
[Rires]
au revoir